- On this episode I get weird.
(exciting music)
♫ You ask the questions
♫ And I answer them
♫ This is
♫ The #AskGaryVee Show ♫
- Hey everybody
this is Gary Vay-ner-chuk,
and this is episode 175
of the #AskGaryVee Show.
That was a little bit
of a different intro.
I'm in a very kind of like,
alright DRock, you can put
on SnapChat, you're having fun
over there.
I'm uh...
I'm not salty.
But I'm in a weirdly passive mood.
- [India] You're physically back too.
- Right, I'm usually like
right up in it, right?
Alright, India, let's get into the show.
- [Voiceover] Brendan Hufford
asks, "Sean Wes mention it,
"but this IFTTT stuff has been
out for awhile, and you used
"to be against it, why change?"
- I guess we talked about
this the other day, right?
But that's for an article, right?
That was in DailyVee 004?
DailyVee 004 is up, by the way.
Please show a screen that's
not clickable, even though it's
within my own channel.
So stupid.
There's a couple reasons,
one the way we've executed the IFTTT,
I only have one IFTTT going on right now,
"If this then that,"
it's a product, you
should all check it out,
it's a tremendously efficient thing.
I talked about in an upcoming article,
but I answer it here on
the show for you as well,
I don't like when automation
replaces something that
should be done by a human.
I don't like when my name
Gary started showing up on
email newsletters with a
different font, Gary, because
it tried to seem like it was personal,
I don't like when you're not
authentic to the audience,
so the execution we have
currently, couple things,
one, I like the way it crops
the picture, accordingly to
Twitter, so that works for
me, comes from Instagram,
where I'm posting a lot.
Two, I'm by hand, I mean,
you know what, actually,
where's my phone?
You've got it.
Right now, check this out, guys,
this is actually happening
in real time, right now,
look it's even on my phone right now,
I was about to do it,
but I didn't have time.
Let me tell you why I'm okay with it.
So, these are the two
images, one for Twitter,
one for Instagram, and the copy for me to
post right now on my social channels,
because DailyVee 004
just came out, right?
So what I used to do, is
I would save these two,
I post one on Instagram type,
and I post one on Twitter.
To me, that's not tricking the audience,
that's just distributing
content, even Facebook now,
I don't post anymore, where,
because I believe the Facebook
fan pages have become content like sites,
and it's okay to schedule
things of that nature,
versus when you get a
reply from me on Twitter,
when I reply in the comments of the,
any comment, I've ever made ever, is me.
Because I think if it's my profile,
if it said Team Gary Vaynerchuk,
it's just about authenticity,
and the other thing
I have with the IFTTT
execution is, the URL is not
like an Instagram URL,
it's actually IFTTT,
so I'm being very clear that
it's coming from somewhere
else, I guess I'm honing in
on my answer of what should
be automated and not,
I think that things that are
perceived as you the human are
doing them by the end audience,
should not be automated,
but automation can work as
long as you're not tricking,
and should work and can
work when it's contextual
distributing the content,
so to me it's really just a
clarification on what I've
always believed, which is if
you're faking the funked of
doing something human, with
automation, that's bad,
but if you're doing for
efficiencies of time,
and there's not confusion
by the end consumer,
then it's good.
And so I guess it's an
evolution of the 2.0 version of
my, because I don't think
I've been clear in the last
decade of, you know, Thank
You Economy and things
that I've talked about, I
do not think that you should
have your assistant, or another
human being reply as you.
The efficiencies we're creating
for the #AskGaryVee book,
Garret and the rest of the
team, and Riley and all
these people, they're not
going to come in and take my
Gary Vee handle and reply
to people to buy the book,
because you're going to think that's me,
they're going to use
the #AskGaryVee handle,
but the automation of a photo
that goes from instagram
to use Twitter as a
distribution channel for that,
that is cropped properly
and things of that nature
I'm comfortable with.
Yeah.
That means it's on you,
India, you ask the next one.
You paused there for a second.
You were waiting for an extra riff?
- No, just sometimes you
have a second thought,
and it seemed like you were going to.
- Got it, that was just
me swallowing my gum.
- [India] You swallowed your gum?
- I have swallowed every
single piece of gum I've chewed
since 1983.
- Living proof that the
old wive's tale is not true.
Gary Vee.
- Well, I mean I'll just die
from gum absorbing my body soon
so there's plenty of time
for gum to absorb my body.
- [India] From Zacharias.
- Zacharias.
- [Voiceover] Zacharias asks,
"What are your thoughts on
"buying a franchise business?
"Love the show by the way."
- Thanks Zacharias, you know
I think a franchise business
is probably very good for a lot of people,
when Burger King and McDonald's and Sonic,
and 7-11, all these kind
of things, when they're
doing the marketing for
you, and by putting that
sign in front of the store,
people are coming into your shop
they deserve those dollars,
and I don't know the model
super well, but I do know a
lot of people that I've met
in my life that are very
well off and very successful,
and when you talk to them,
"hey how did that guy do it,
"or how did that gal make their money?"
"Oh, they own 79 KFCs."
So, I think the more
interesting question is,
is a franchise business right for you?
If you're not good at building brand,
if you're not good at getting customers,
but you're a good operator,
you work hard, you're
looking for steady income,
that may be a great business.
If you're a great marketer,
like a franchise business for me
would be idiotic, because
I'm a great marketer,
I can get people to show up
to things, I can get people
to come in, why would I give
up part of the action to
somebody who's doing that as well?
So if I was to start a burger
shop I would never go with
a franchise, I'd create my own thing.
But, the business model's
fine, it's been around
for 50, 60, 70 years, it's
a great way for people with
less dollars to be successful
because a lot of the work's
being done for you,
and so I like the model,
but I think the question is,
is it the right model for you?
Make sure you know your skill
sets, and all the monies
that you're giving up to
corporate by kicking them
dollars, are they bringing
you value for those dollars?
I've definitely heard of
people that have started out
in franchise business, realized,
aw, crap, I'm good at these
things, like there
wasn't a marriage there.
But for people that are not marketers,
and don't know how to get
asses in seats, I think it's
a very good model.
- [India] From Shaun.
Shaun.
- [Voiceover] Shaun asks, "Lots
of people on Snapchat don't
"let followers snap them.
"If personal brands don't
use it as a two-way street,
"aren't they missing the point?"
- I think that they're missing something,
I've been feverishly, and, you
know, send me a message right
now on Snapchat and ask
me to friend you up,
I'll try to do as many as I
can, problem with Snapchat is,
all your messages don't save,
they start to go away if
you get too many like I do,
like I can't get in the queue,
so you gotta keep kinda
pinging me, a little bit,
which stinks,
meaning like, I can't keep scrolling,
yeah, well you don't get
like hundreds of messages
an hour.
- [India] I know.
- I'm kidding, that was
just a razz for fun,
you probably are.
You know, so,
that kinda stinks, but
yeah, I do think that,
when you look at Mike, who
has been winning on it,
and some of the other
people, some of the early
people who are following the blueprint,
you know, by the way, real quick,
everybody's kind of
yapping at me right now,
like "oh you're pushing Snapchat so hard,"
you guys have been very close to the show,
nobody was saying that about Facebook with
me last year and that's
all I talked about, right?
Or Instagram, just 'cause it's the first,
they've never seen it
happen in an early stage,
they kinda caught me
mid-Facebook thesis when
I started the show, guys
this will happen again,
if this show continues,
and like Shmooga Mooga,
like that's all I'll talk
about until I feel like I've
totally, anyway,
yes, look, the answer is
they're not missing the point,
they're playing, it means
that these personalities,
are playing the width
game, not the depth game,
let me explain.
If you just keep it as
you're a content pusher,
and people want to see you
dressed sexy or business
advice, or whatever the hell
you're doing, if you're just
doing that and you're
not engaging with people,
first of all, female personal
brands have it different,
I mean I've already talked to
multiple of my female friends,
on the (expletive) that
they're getting, from leaving
their Snapchat open, it's like...
It's not good.
That's number one,
number two, for the guys in the crowd,
it's a complete no-brainer
if you want to create depth,
for women, unfortunately this
is just life, it's a little
trickier for me to give blanket advice,
but clearly, you know,
as a matter of fact,
question of the day,
whether it happened on Twitter, or whether
it happened on email, or
whether it's happening
right now on Snapchat,
has me personally responding,
in a world where I've
done 'em all, by the way,
from the prior question,
has that impacted how you
feel about me.
That's the question of the day.
And the answer's gonna be
yes, from a lot of people,
right, like people appreciate
effort, and that engagement,
and so when the question's
being asked, are they missing
the boat, I do, I think
they're missing an opportunity
people are affected by what
they're outwardly putting,
but if they took one second
and said thanks, or hello,
or yeah, I said "yeah,
Holland" to some guy today,
you know, if they do that, I
literally believe that that
person will pay more attention
do more things with them,
biz-dev more with them,
care about them longer,
and I think there's a real ROI
for that little extra effort,
even though it's work.
I mean, it's work.
- A video from Daymond, Power of Broke.
- Oh!
- It's kinda long, but--
- When did he put this out?
- Just today.
- What's up, Gary Vay-ner-chuk?
(chuckles)
I think I got it.
This is Daymond John,
they peo-ple's shark.
- The people's shark?
- Now as you know I am
a huge fan of the show.
That kind of reminds me
of when Dr. Evil said,
"who, his what? Fajah, his fajah!" anyway,
don't worry about that, so,
now you know I have my new book out called
"The Power of Broke,"
uh, DRock can you do me
a favor just put that link up--
- DRock getting some love,
Staphon you got dissed.
- Now, here's my question for you,
we already know your history,
we know your history of
coming up from nothing and
learning how to turn around
this amazing business you
have, and now you have a huge
empire, you have an empire
where people like sharks follow
you and have a huge
amount of respect for you,
so I know you know how to
apply the power of broke,
because you did it back
then and you do it now.
But, now you're spending your
own money and you're investing
in many many startups and
many people out there,
how are you making sure
that they are applying the
power of broke?
Because of course when somebody
doesn't apply the power of
broke, they take in money they
just think they can go buy
everything it's going to make
life better but that's not the
case, and more importantly,
after they apply the power of
broke, how are you making
sure they keep the mentality,
so that when they get to this
point in life, they keep the
power of broke mentality
to ensure success?
- I love him.
D, thanks so much for the question,
also you are clearly a branding genius,
you've said "Power of Broke"
so many times that I think
I'm going to say power
broke 15 more times and if
you keep saying it it just becomes real,
you know Daymond, I actually
think it's impossible to do.
I think it's very hard to teach broke.
I don't know how to instill, I
mean I'm, forget about all my
investments, I'm scared
crapless of how I'm going to
teach my kids that, because
they're going to be in
the power of rich, that's
Misha and Xander, I'm calling
you out, you're soft.
So, I mean look it's very
hard to instill those virtues,
and I don't know that
I've been successful as an
entrepreneur who's become
an investor of instilling
that into my investment,
uh, investments at all,
I think what I've done well
is I've recognized what
they may be good at, oh
you're not the power of
hustle and broke and all
that, but you know what you
are, you came from a rich family,
you are seriously educated
and I think you really
understand operations,
and your number two looks
like they're pretty hungry
and broke, like I really
haven't, I don't think it's fair,
to think that we can
instill the power of broke
in the same way that I don't
think anybody can instill
into me the hashtag of
power of prep school, right?
Like it's just not a part of
that DNA, and so I think that's
a challenge, as a matter
of fact, I don't read,
though I tried an audio
book on my vacation
and it didn't go so bad, and
you can do two times speed,
it was pretty cool.
Um, so I'm really interested
in how you approach this with
the book, and like how much,
like how do you, how do
you instill hustle, or things
of that nature, has been
interesting, as outside
investing, it's been very hard
for me, internally, I
do think you can do it.
I've been very, in the same
way probably mom and dad
AJ probably instilled that into us, right?
'Cause they worked hard?
Good, thanks AJ, don't
worry do your thing,
see he's hustling so
hard he's not listening,
So, in the same way that
my parents showed me
work ethic, and it was instilled
in me, I definitely see
I think India works harder
today, capture that,
India do you truly think you work harder,
forget about smarter, do
you think you work harder
because you've been so close
to, if I'm the sun of hustle,
what?
- You're a copywriter.
- But do you think you
work harder because of it?
- Yeah, just from being around you.
- Don't you agree with that bro?
It rubs off, things rub off.
- Of course, of course, absolutely.
- It's like how you start
saying the same words--
- 100 percent, like I'm
going to say power of broke
all day.
I do think, as an investor,
and I have empathy, I know what
you do, it's on TV, I get it,
it's hard to do that from afar
close, in the same way I think
I'll be able to pull it off
with my kids, I think as an
organization for a lot of you
that have three, four, seven,
nine, 12 employees, I do think
you can instill it, and it's
a very funny way you do it.
By doing it.
Only actions.
Actions, actions, actions.
The only way I think you can
do it is by you, the leader
of a company, acting a
certain way, and people,
you agree with that on AJ?
AJ's into that one.
So, I guess Daymond,
if you can spend enough
time with your investments, and they can,
I think one of the ways that,
you know, you know what's
actually crazy?
I actually have figured out
a weird way how to do it,
it's called DailyVee,
I've had multiple people
that are investments of mine,
email me about the first
three episodes, the
fourth one just went up,
the three episodes of
DailyVee, and be like,
you might be working harder
than me, and I haven't
even made it yet.
So, actions.
- [India] Awesome.
- Cool.
- [India] Last one.
- Last one.
- [Voiceover] Jing 1990 asks,
"Have you ever released a
"subpar product or service?
"If so, why?
"What did you learn from it?"
- Tons of times, I learned
that if I don't apply all my
energy into something it
can't be as good as it can be,
I mean, all day, always.
'Cause I'm always testing,
I'm always doing things,
like didn't we launch
a (expletive) Gary app?
That I was gonna engage with everybody on?
Like, yeah, Vee Chat.
I mean, the answer is a lot.
A lot, a lot, a lot of things.
Gourmet library never took off.
What I learned is, unless
I am 100 percent all in on
something, it is vulnerable.
Doesn't mean it's not going
to work, it means that
it is vulnerable, and even if
I have a great leader in place
the only way that I've been
able to guarantee success
is for me to micro-manage
the operations of that.
I've had successes when I
didn't do that up front,
but what I've learned is,
I try to bite off more than
I can chew, my vulnerability
as an entrepreneur always
is big eyes, I think I can do
everything, I literally think
I can force in my 17 hour days,
everything through victory
I've become much more aware
of that from 35 to 40,
I still do it because I
get enjoyment out of it,
like just having a lot
going on is exciting for me,
but I can afford that enjoyment today,
doesn't mean it's right,
trying to be smarter about that
too, trying to make them
be very very enjoyable,
or have a much better chance
of winning, but the answer
is tons of times I've
launched subpar products,
mainly because I wasn't
150 percent behind it,
and because, and really to
give you guys more value,
one thing I've learned, a
lot of times I'll start with
something and being 150
percent in it, and then very
quickly it becomes 100, then 80, then 70,
and they all have different timings,
sometimes, I've gotten
better at eliminating
the things that I'm 150 percent into,
and letting it sit for
more than like a week,
to allow myself to see if
it's still at a buck 50,
and then if it's at a
buck 20 I'm like, I'm out.
But if it's a buck 50 for a month or two,
and then I'll go, so yeah,
if you're not in it, you're
not in it.
Good, I asked a question of the day.
I feel like this office makes weird shows.
- [India] What book did you listen to?
- Uh, Walter Isaacson wrote
a book about innovators,
right?
It's big fat new book, he's
the guy who did the Steve Jobs
book, it was kinda interesting.
Double speed was interesting.
He didn't read it, which I disrespected.
I think all authors should
read their audio books.
- [AJ] Aren't you not reading your own?
- I'm reading.
- The whole thing?
- I'm reading the whole thing.
Oh, I have questions being
read, but the answers
is like,
the questions wasn't my writing,
they were questions,
but thanks for the razz.
- [AJ] Any time.
- You keep asking questions,
such a weird mood, I'm
in like (expletive),
this is as weird as it
gets, and it's coming off
of, this is back to back weird.
There's people, double
weird, like book end
weird.
It's because I'm in a very like--
(laughing)
Time?
I'm in a very weird mood, see you later.
(bass heavy music)